deux bureaux se trouvent sur un jeu qui
s'appelait with mais c'est un jeu
d'horreur développé par des français et
du coup on va dire le titre en français
jouent avec moi
voilà finalement bayard est permise mais
c'est un jeu d'horreur gratuit qui a
l'air absolument terrifiant et dans
lequel on ne s'ennuie pas m'avez-vous 10
personnes même cette chanson je vois
déjà tous les mecs qui opère des clones
fuir mort est là restez tout va bien se
passer presse et les quelques stars elle
est partie je suis sûr que tu as envie
de jouer ouais mais ne me regarde jamais
dans les yeux un décor le mec c'est une
racaille pas le regardant les deux sinon
il te vole donc téléphone sauf si tu
veux mourir à ce but n'aura qu'à l'as
haguenau star trouve les quatre bougies
pour résoudre le puzzle puis prend la
clé qui te permettra de retrouver la
liberté
ok oh non non j'espère qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de blabla pour retarder le
moment où on allait jouer au hockey
6 okc and dolls rouge et prennent ok
super on est une bougie du coup
fantastique faut concevoir par ou par là
et en double à parcourir ils ont une
manière de tuer les oreilles c'est leur
petit kiff apparemment il n'ya pas de
clown et s'il faut descendre et une
porte là bas on dans le doute j'ai vu un
truc rouge en bas ça me plaît pas rouge
comme l'enfer rouge comme le nez du
clown rouge comme tu as joué après que
ta mère tu es puni puisque tu geek trop
call of duty ce trop long au quoi il ya
un bruit de claquement fort ne pense pas
que la caisse est encore plus flippant
mais que comme jacques vabre west bay
est déjà membre est alors attends qu est
ce qu on voit là un jeu puisque on a là
un placard qu'est-ce qu'on a là une
porte
ok on wheels à la waho pour pourquoi
c'est quoi c'est que ça c'est le bon
état d'esprit qui traversent la route
c'est ça une salle de bains dans
laquelle il y aura jamais de bouger les
90 salles de bain ça rien c'est un dû
toucher n'importe quoi alors avance là
on a quoi on est de retour dans un
couloir mais je vais tout est parti
rui deuxième pont aux ânes les binômes
beach ok on va apprendre à bouger à je
me suis fait mal à la boit je l'entends
c'est un petit peu irrité là dedans je
dois reprendre un strip cl avec un peu
de miel 1 auquel nous en reste deux à
prendre il nous reste deux à prendre
tout ça c'était juste pour quoi choquer
à temps à descendre les escaliers
peut-être qu'il est en train de faire le
clown etc c'est leur droit mais qu'il
perd tellement pas de temps ce clown ça
dégage
oh non non je t'ai pas y aller dans les
yeux arrête arrête arrête arrête arrête
quand je te regarde dans les yeux tu ne
fais pas ça troisième bouger mon gars il
ya des bruits de partout c'est quoi il
bouge c'est quoi en fait ces bruits
pourquoi puis bruit d'un coup at home
c'est terrifiant monga bordel de merde
arrête je ne retournerais pas j'espère
comme parce que je dis quoi scandaleux
alors oui ou le coup de l'écran on
connaît bien relancé s'assombrit ok bah
l ago au ballet à gauche
ok à tendance mais qu'elle a hautmont
après la porte d'entrée sur mais qu'est
ce qu'une boucle du faux dans le garage
monga à gros il se passe trop de choses
se passent trop jeune mon petit coeur
n'assume plus mon petit coeur va mourir
attends je ne sais pas j'étais prêt pour
rien cg oui on va passer la hôpital mrc
c'est quoi ça c'est juste du linge
étendu [ __ ] mais n'importe quoi et
pourquoi la lumière septembre à de
sérieux la pression ok d'or ça s'ouvre
qu'on arrête c'est une cuisine eux
attendent mais qu on trouve ta gueule on
trouve une bougie sur le capot de la
voiture s'il ya pas de bougies dans la
cuisine c'est un scandale à cesson
toujours dans une c'est un vieux placard
péter que tout une fois par an justement
que c'est ton anniversaire prenez bouger
arrête ta journée
oh [ __ ] hop n'a ni comment est ce tu
as bien lu tout comme barack obama la
nhtsa
je sais pas chez moi j'aimais ça elle
veut vendre pas s'ouvrir et renfermé et
ben voilà on va dans le couloir sombre
et humide qu'on évite tous j'atterris ou
là dans la salle à manger de nouveau à
parce que je passe toutes les bougies
d'accord ça doit être la pièce que
j'ouvre avec la clé pour retrouver ma
liberté alors j'ai dû passer à côté
d'une bougie
je pense que c'est la fin c'est les
marches n'importe quoi attachez train de
me perdre en train de devenir fou c'est
le clown qui va en fout c'est ça j'ai
extrêmement peur je peux qu aller par là
je peux tu allais par la moyenne
pourquoi je tourne en rond comme une
merde logiquement est à mon avis un
placard vrai ici c'est sûr il y en a
forcément dans la cuisine il peut pas ne
pas y en avoir dans la cuisine the
parlant doucement comme si le j'ai peur
que le coût ne m'entend ya pas une
bougie à la plaque à allez arrête de 8o
dans une boîte à pizza possible soit
possible je compris j'ai dû oublier en
turquie où elle est forcément là aussi
ça fait deux fois que fait le tour dans
ma [ __ ] de clown oh merde a maudit
sois tu que cette pièce là je les fais
pourquoi mais la clé mais oui mon dieu
c'est ça qui nous manquait ok la mecque
le coût du base de voile à l'école de
maastricht il a vu qu'on avait la clé il
va nous péter le cul ah non il ya
travail apporte faut passer par le pont
c'est ça ouais la salle de bain on n'a
pas envie de mourir noyé dans un lavabo
un tu m'appelles [ __ ] c'est pas le
moment là c'est pas le moment là c'est
mon psy et reçoit maison négative il m'a
déjà appelé où elle a par exemple
ok mais qui a tout les par la vision 4
pas de se claquer mais sauf que moi ce
que je sais c'est que la porte par
laquelle son fût elle est là elle est
juste là bas le clou lice dégage adore
le cloud et la migrer vers watts
c'est le nez du clown c'est le nez du
clown c'est le nez du clown
et bien franchement bravo aux étudiants
français parce qu'il se passe ministre
qui a raison dans ce jeu c à c ur monga
le gars qui courent les bruits et
machins et c'est souvent ce que je
croise dans les jeux d'horreur qu'on
fait c'est que il se passe rien voilà il
ya juste deux trois avantages dans un
temps on voit jamais le truc qui nous
qui nous poursuit qui va sûrement nous
couper la gorge dans d'affreuses
souffrances alors que là tu le vois il
est light souri à la gueule il se moque
j'ai bien aimé je suis déçu on aurait
aimé que le jeu dure plus longtemps en
purée il a fallu sécher les cours et
passer plus de temps à l'écho des uns ne
fait pas ça à 13 heures prochaines une
auberge de me regarder portez vous bien
de châteauroux baisse 1,2 voilà j'ai
fait